call me dude Z Bill Clinton Timothy
chalamet recording artist Pink they've
all been there the fifth way of dudes
evening is the way of the [ __ ] it anyone
celebrating dudes evening can indulge in
one astonishing meal that might
otherwise be prohibited by dietary
restrictions will in chat you must
indulge in whatever meal you desire this
is the way of the [ __ ] it begin
I got a case of the Wednesday fuckets
and you know this year dude's evening
falls on a Wednesday yes so this is a
legitimate Wednesday [ __ ] it yeah
two pepperoni pizzas a cheeseburger I
got loaded potato skins and some trouble
so what what are you gonna eat I mean we
have to eat these meals now uh you know
uh some leftover uh Italian seafood
would be good A little peaked a little
gamey you know the clams start to they
start to sweat they got a sour no
um any meal any meal at all dudesi is
going to let us have our favorite thing
you know not too long ago in the show uh
Chad when we're talking about the liver
King I called myself the liver and
onions King because I loved liver and
onions as a kid but uh another thing I
really loved was uh
I haven't had this since well
Molly uh makes me on my birthday she
always makes me a special version of
this but it's a little hers is like a
little bit like it's kicked up she does
like a a grilled kind of thing but I
always loved just white toast butter and
some thick cut bologna that's kind of in
a way that's kind of my favorite food of
all time uh I mean I love good country
Japanese and good country Italian but in
a lot of ways that's my favorite food of
all time uh like Van Halen's 1984 is my
favorite album what would yours be
um
my favorite food of all time is the
gruel um but I'm not I'm not going after
what is my favorite here I think for me
I mean if if this is truly a Wednesday
[ __ ] it I'm gonna eat something that I
have not eaten in four ish years it's a
steak a ribeye steak on the boat 16
ounce Ribeye it's not that nope it is a
McDonald's apple pie
oh
dude when was the last time you
because a lot of people who are vegan no
you can't because vegetarians will eat
at McDonald's because they'll get like a
whatever there's all sorts of options
but aside from the fact that you eat
very healthy you wouldn't go near when
was last time you ate at McDonald's over
four years ago
wow all right so I guess we got to
prepare these things you have to go make
it you wanna you
we have to
go bad yeah
go to the grocery store and I have to go
to a restaurant
oh man all right this is but look at
that look at this dude what do you got I
believe you're gonna eat McDonald's I
can't either
um I'm curious if I can even take a
[ __ ] bite of this because the How
Sweet It Is might be repulsive to me I
don't know but I do remember the
McDonald's apple pie when I was a kid
was fried now it's baked
mm-hmm
what do you got there oh I thought I
thought for some reason you were opening
a sauce you're gonna put like honey
mustard on the [ __ ] thing that would
have been disgusting no I'm just gonna
eat it as it is oh okay go for it cheers
dude chills dudes evening the chill
dude's evening to you oh man look at
that oh boy all right
um
holy [ __ ] look at how thick that [ __ ]
is
it's good stuff
well
this is a good idea this is pretty good
oh
why don't you give me
a dudes evening greeting
that's a guy have a chill dude's evening
sir dude I gotta say this Trail dudes
evening to you this is very good yeah um
yeah it's better than I remembered I am
able to handle the uh
the sugars in it I think yeah I'm gonna
eat this whole thing
wow McDonald's apple pie dude I
sincerely have not had this in many
years
this is not good um
uh pod showing when you're eating on a
pod show but it has to be done because
it's Duty
it's dudes evening it's a celebration
lulio likes it too oh Jesus I gave
myself
oh [ __ ] I gave myself the hiccups okay
hey you know why
I gave myself the hiccups because I ate
this baloney sandwich too fast yeah dude
get a drink
yeah that's a good idea now I'm holding
the dog
my [ __ ] bologna sandwich and my big
bottle
want some water I just poured it on
myself hey you know why lulio would like
a [ __ ] bologna sandwich hmm because
it's got that pink meat dude it's got
that pink foam there you go buddy oh
yeah oh yeah get some of that oh yeah
there he goes all right hey you want to
buy my bologna sandwich now that lulio
had some no you know how you like to
kiss him on the mouth
all right hey you know what
I'm not having a [ __ ] tremendous time
yeah I gotta say this is unexpected how
much I like this [ __ ] apple pie
I'm gonna give lulio I'm not sure that
I'll ever eat it again but maybe next
dude's evening or something but God damn
it's as good as I remembered this is the
best dude's evening ever it's the first
dude's evening and it's not even dude's
evening yet it's dudes evening Eve right
I just want to wish Chad will and all
the other pods are very happy dudes
evening now enjoy some drum marijuana
that's actually not not a bad idea this
is not a bad idea
a chill dude's evening to You children's
evening to you sir hey we got some pot
uh lulio's not with us because when we
smoke a little marijuana
or turmer marijuana
it's not good to have the dog now are we
having a great time or what you got some
of that oh you still got some of that
left eh yeah I got a bite or two left of
this apple pie for my what was it the
fifth wave dude seasoning is the way of
the [ __ ] it the fifth that's right well
hold on a second dude I got a bologna
sandwich a lighter and a joint in my
hand brother
and that's how you know you're having a
chill dude's evening dude you talk about
the way of the past you talk about the
way of the present the way of the future
and then you talk about a shitty movie
like lawnmower man dude it wasn't a
shitty movie
hey you know what my hiccups are gone
there are a lot of great things about
that movie yeah yeah dude
um I'll tell you what let me tell you
something
uh the you know what's a good thing to
cure your hiccups McDonald's apple pie
uh bologna sandwich and some pot
um this might be the best [ __ ]
episode ever just from where I'm sitting
hey you know what would have been a good
AI podcast to come in and and
um have US host it instead of doozy the
bologna sandwich and pot podcast yep
speaking of free will
that well that's a podcast I'd like to
do dude
um and another podcast you're doing
right now brother yeah brother that's
and I'll tell you another thing about
free will God damn it was good thanks
McDonald's
see you in another four years maybe
thanks baloney thanks thanks incredible
industrial uh the the industrial
advances that brought us bologna who the
[ __ ] figured that out
what's up baloney baloney probably some
dude who owned a slaughterhouse and was
like you know we can sell the steaks and
we can sell the bacon and we can sell
all this stuff but what about this [ __ ]
that's just all over the [ __ ] floor
that has dirt in it and blood and
intestines and [ __ ] and all those chairs
all the butcher poor suit sweeping how
can we make money off that oh why don't
we just put it in a cylindrical [ __ ]
mold and press it together into some
kind of mystery meat well it's a sausage
I guess you know when you look at an
entire baloney it's just a sausage is
what it is technically um
yeah when I was a kid that's when I knew
it was uh that's when I knew it was uh
it was on and popping when I look into
my lunch my lunch bag
and see that baloney sandwich in the
clear plastic oh boy I couldn't wait
dude it was my favorite as a kid too I
love to [ __ ] baloney slice of
American cheese mayonnaise and then you
take a Lay's barbecue chips crunch them
up and put a layer of that [ __ ] over the
bologna and then put your bread on shut
up and get out that was great really
yeah that's amazing that Chad would eat
that if you think about that now
that's next dude's evening next dude's
evening we have to eat the uh the other
person's meal we're getting ready dude
what do you mean it's not meat it's pink
foam it's mostly sawdust hell no or
mayonnaise or [ __ ] cheese is is blood
a meat
yeah it's a meat it comes from Corpse
yeah that's what Chad likes to call it
when I eat that [ __ ] corpse dude well uh
yeah enjoy your corpse brother that's
some real anime [ __ ] this this is people
that eat corpses I particularly like
just smoking weed whenever I feel like
it
I think most people most people like it
like that just whenever you feel like it
yeah I agree
yeah it does feel like dudes evening is
you know it feels like it's almost here
who's starting to get rid
excited
[Music]
thank you moving on please
do do
please